hey everybody come here and welcome back
to reality check
there are you excited about the future
of virtual reality in gaming I know I
genuinely am but I also know we spend a
lot of time talking exclusively about
oculus rift but you know what there are
others out there vying for a piece of
this new virtual reality pie so this
week I scoured the Internet to bring you
six of the best alternatives to oculus
rift Sony ever heard of them nah me
neither
apparently they make video game consoles
or some rubbish but let's not hold that
against them as they are also no
stranger to the virtual reality space
producing a piece of kit called the sony
h MZ t3 a VR unit marketed as a theater
virtualization headset costing just a
whisker below $1,000 it simulates
watching a screen 700 to 750 inches in
size from 65 feet away the headset now
in its third iteration has a display
consisting of jewell OLED screens
delivering a cool 720p resolution per
eye it's worth noting that this is
actually inferior to the latest oculus
rift model Crystal Cove which delivers a
full 1080p per eye now while this unit
can be used for gaming in some
circumstances the primary use for the HM
zt3 like its predecessors is media
viewing watching movies on planes for
example or in tiny New York apartments
however fret not PlayStation fans as
Sony have also recently teased the
existence of a dedicated ps4 VR headset
set for a grand unveiling at GDC later
this month keep your eyes on GameSpot
for all the news on this one as it comes
okay I think this next one is perhaps my
favorite of all the devices on this list
say hello to the glyph from a baguette
so what makes it so special well unlike
all other competitors on the market it
doesn't use an LCD or OLED screen to
produce the image in fact there is no
screen at all now this one projects two
discreet images directly into the eyes
of the wearer mimicking the way we see
objects in real life Texas Instruments
DLP technology is used to project a 1280
by 800 display right onto your retinas
currently it's a man alpha prototype
phase and kind of looks like a really
giant pair of headphones to label of
your simply full divisor down and you're
good to go the image produced is
relative to an 80 inch television screen
eight feet in front of you and as such
doesn't quite fill your entire field of
view in the same way as say the oculus
according to GameSpot sister site
cnet.com the image clarity however is
pretty much unparalleled due to this
projection technology senior editor
Scott Stein commented that the projected
image was exceedingly bright and vivid
lacking any sense of pixelation a
deep-sea 3d movie looked like it was
projected in a tiny little movie theater
in front of my eyes he said the glyph
has an all-encompassing HDMI input to
boot allowing it to connect happily to a
wide variety of input sources including
phones blu-ray players and the like
although designed primarily with movie
viewing in mind it's not difficult to
see its potential for gaming the glyph
massively exceeded its Kickstarter goal
as well so fingers crossed we'll get to
see a beta prototype of this soon if
nothing quite gets you going like a
crazy wide field of view and take note
of the infinite eye now the oculus rift
sets the standard at around 90 degrees
horizontally with others falling within
ten or so degrees of that mark however
this aesthetic monstrosity has a
staggering horizontal field of 210
degrees that's a view they'll have your
eyes rolling around almost as much as
your goofy goofy head designed by a trio
of Frenchmen in Toulouse the unit
comprises of four
render screens as opposed to the typical
to now you have two renders directly in
front of your eyes with the addition of
outward sideways facing render screens
for your peripheral vision when you
think of accomplishing the next step in
creating a believable and immersive
environment it almost seems obvious but
it does come at a price
not only literal but also in its
dimensions in a reasonably successful
bid to solve the problem the team has
opted for Fresnel lenses rather than
heavier glass ones but alas at its
current state of production this is a
cumbersome piece of kit and we can only
wait to see what they can do to make
this a more comfortable accessory my
word it's like I'm really here up next
we have the game face mark for at first
glance you could be forgiven for
thinking that it's just the oculus rift
but in white well keep looking and you
should notice that there aren't any
wires it's all self-contained
while the oculus rift needs an input
device to run the PC say everything you
need to get gaming with the game faces
right there on your face the processing
power comes from an Android OS so
obviously when compared with a PC
connected rift it's gonna come in second
place in the graphics race however to
really get the most from a
self-contained setup the company is in
talks with Nvidia to potentially
incorporate its new k1 chip which would
give it that extra boost in processing
power as well as support for the Unreal
Engine 4 plus they're also planning on
building out a dedicated Android VR
store to further support the headset
which is pretty exciting
finally what if I told you that the
majority of the hardware that you need
to experience a virtual reality
environment is already in your pocket
nope it's not that piece of lint in a
stick of gum it's your phone and it's
the key to the dive VR headset from the
folks at Derulo's simple in its design
this mask holds your iOS or Android
phone inches from your eyes and with the
use of lenses magnifies your field of
view it's kind of like the oculus rift
to be honest but instead of having a
screen and a computer to power the
software both these jobs are done by
your phone also by taking full advantage
of the gyroscopes and accelerometers of
your device the reverse acknowledge that
you already own the bulk of the expense
and technology necessary hence it's sub
$100 retail price however because it is
taking advantage of your phone and it's
processing power this also becomes the
limiting factor at the best of times
smartphones have undependable battery
life and while processors are getting
increasingly powerful you will still be
a long ways of oculus and PC
capabilities plus you won't want to get
a business call whilst hitting Mach 3 on
a virtual roller coaster so what do you
make of these alternatives to oculus
rift let me know in the comments down
below or you can reach out to me on
twitter at camp Fras Rob or just use the
hashtag GS reality last week on reality
check I tackled the science of knocking
people out for hours towards the end of
the episode I discussed potential
alternatives to bossing people on the
head as a way of non-lethal e taking
them down for a long period of time and
loads of you asked a really great
question about the possibility of using
a choke or sleeper hold
so would this work well what a choke or
sleeper hold actually does is stop the
blood flow and thus the oxygen supply to
the brain by compressing the arteries
this results in a loss of consciousness
however as soon as the hold is released
blood flow resumes and the person should
rapidly regain consciousness overall
you're probably talking a lapse of 15
seconds or so any longer than that and
once again you're probably doing some
nasty irreversible brain damage so yeah
not a really viable alternative for
safely killing guards for a
long period of time okay thanks for
watching everybody and make sure you
come back next week
for more reality check